SPEAKER 1: Hello.
I'm Timothy Jordan.
Today, I'm coming to
you from the YouTube
space in Los Angeles.
And this is your update about
the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
CSS Paint API, also known as CSS
Custom Paint or Houdini's Paint
Worklet--
allows you to
programmatically generate
an image whenever a CSS
property expects an image.
It's also about to be enabled
by default in Chrome Stable.
To learn more about what it is
and what you can do with it,
head on over to the post linked
in the description below.
Version 21 of the Flutter plugin
is now available and includes
the new Flutter Inspector.
The inspector works in
IntelliJ and Android Studio,
and makes it much easier to
understand why your application
is rendering the way it does.
For more details
on this release,
head on over to the post.
The Google Play Games Services
C++ SDK Version 3.0 is now
available.
Highlights include bug
fixes for the Nearby API,
refinements in the
Snapshots API, and more.
Links to the SDK and
samples are on the post.
OpenCensus is the
open source version
of Google's Census
library based on years
of optimization experience.
It's a vendor-neutral
single distribution
of libraries that automatically
collects traces and metrics
from your app, displays them
locally, and sends them over
to analysis tools.
Head on over to the post for
screenshots and links to code.
Universal App
Campaigns makes it easy
for you to reach users and grow
your app business at scale.
It uses Google's Machine
Learning technology
to help you find the customers
that matter most to you
based on your business goals
across Google Play, Google.com,
YouTube and the millions
of sites and apps
in the Display Network.
Today, we're launching a new
interactive education program
for Universal App Campaigns.
The link to the
course is on the post.
Please remember to like,
subscribe, and share.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
I'll see you next week.
Thanks for watching this
week's episode of the "Dev
Show." if you'd like to catch
some of our prior episodes,
they're right over here.
[MUSIC PLAYING]